c'est le chiffre record de ces enchères
un cheval vendus par le haras des
monceaux aujourd'hui difficile d'en
espérer autant mais les quatorze poulain
restants devraient avoir du succès pour
obtenir les meilleurs pur-sang anglais
à peine âgée de 2 ans les potentiels
acheteurs n'hésitent pas à mettre le
prix pour le directeur des écuries
ces montants sont à la hauteur du
travail fourni par les éleveurs on voit
des esprits qui sont spectaculaires mais
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
derrière il ya énormément
d'investissement énormément de main
d'oeuvre des saillies des juments qu'il
faut renouveler régulièrement mais c'est
une très belle récompense et c'est
formidable pour toute l'équipe quand ça
arrivera avant les dernières ventes
courtiers et investisseurs scrutent
morphologie harmonie muscles et poils du
cheval sont examinées mais pas
d'inquiétude les caractéristiques des
chevaux des monceaux sont réputés le
haras fait partie des meilleurs vendeurs
de deauville depuis dix ans
ce sont des gagnants mais quand ils sont
sur la piste le niveau d'élevage est
très élevé c'est vraiment le hayon
d'habitude j'essaie d'en acheter le plus
possible parce que j'ai confiance
directeur est un bon ami à moi est
vraiment très professionnel il excelle
et c'est ce que veulent les acheteurs un
dernier tour de piste avant le moment
fatidique
un dernier coup d'oeil pour se décider
cette fois ci une concession
aujourd'hui même si les enchères ne bat
pas de record
au total ces trois jours devant tours
ont rapporté près de 10 millions d'euros
aux arts a dénoncé